bonjour david expliquez-nous ce qui
suscite la colère des syndicats
bien écouter à sophie ce qui suscite la
colère des syndicats vous l'avez dit
l'objet de la contestation cette
dislocation d'edf en plusieurs entités
qui pourrait être privatisé dans le
futur un accord qui aurait été trouvé
entre bruxelles et le gouvernement il y
a deux ans l'opposition et les syndicats
pointent du doigt justement cet accord
et je me trouve justement avec nicolas
dupont aignan en tant qu'élu politique
pour vous c'était important de soutenir
cette mobilisation aujourd'hui devant
l'assemblée nationale
oui parce que on peut pas accepter qu'un
des as tu de la france qui offre une
électricité quasiment deux fois moins
cher qu'en allemagne qui permet à nos
concitoyens de pas payer trop cher
encore ça augmente trop et à nos
entreprises est compétitive on peut pas
accepter de voir détruit ce qu'on
construit nos grands parents nos parents
d'être privatisée c'est-à-dire à terme
des pénuries d'électricité augmentation
des tarifs
c'est ça la réalité c'est qu'on est en
train de détruire un atout on n'a pas
tant d'atouts ça en france pour accepter
de voir edf coupé en morceaux et est
vendue au plus offrant
est-ce que d'une certaine manière c'est
un symbole de la république est touchée
puisque nationalisé l'électricité
c'était juste après la seconde guerre
mondiale on s'en souvient est ce que
c'est une sorte d' atteinte aux symboles
de la république
c'est surtout une atteinte à quelque
chose qui a marché on produit
l'électricité la moins chère décarbonés
décarbonés et donc c'est aujourd'hui il
ya le lancement du projet climatique et
on va détruire l'outil qui permet de
faire des économies de carbone mais faut
être malade ce c'est très grave pour moi
c'est vraiment de la haute trahison de
l'intérêt national haute trahison
j'assiste ya une mobilisation qui est
assez importante aujourd'hui devant
l'assemblée nationale pourquoi parce que
y'a l'audition au site afin de l'adf et
de bruno le maire ministre de l'économie
qui est ce que vous en espérez de cette
audition bon on va voir moi je ne suis
pas membre de cette commission mais je
vais la suivre et je souhaite qu'on
montre les contradictions parce que
c'est pas en démantelant un outil où il
ya des synergies en séparant en
compliquant l'organisation qu'on va et
plus efficace il faut être efficace il
faut continuer à avoir des avantages
et puis il faut arrêter de subventionner
les éoliennes et les panneaux solaires
qui ne marche pas quand il fait froid ou
qui a pas de vent et qui font qu'on
importe du charbon ont confié marché des
centrales à charbon ou à gaz qui
polluent beaucoup plus donc on est en
plein délire
c'est à dire que on ferme des unités
nucléaire qui ne produit pas de carbone
et on est en train de mettre en place un
système compliqué qui va produire plus
de carbone donc c'est complètement
contradictoire avec les grands objectifs
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
voilà vous l'aurez compris en tout cas
la contestation ici dure cet après midi
et c'est assez symbolique comme vous
l'aurez compris puisqu'il ya l'audition
du président d'edf est un de vos deux le
maire de ministre de l'économie afin de
contester ce projet hercules qui
entraînerait en en partie une
privatisation d'edf
merci beaucoup david khalifa depuis l
assemblée nationale